Avant toute chose, je rappelle que cette chaîne n'est pas faite à la base pour réviser le bac.
C'est juste une chaîne faite pour parler ensemble de philo de manière fun.
De facto, il y a pas mal de gens qui l'utilisent pour ça, donc je fais cette vidéo.
Yo ! C'est Cyrus, c'est bientôt le bac de philo,
et ces derniers jours, c'est un petit peu fou tout ce qui se passe sur la chaîne :
vous êtes beaucoup à venir, je reçois plein de commentaires, plein de remerciements, etc.
Ça fait vachement vachement plaisir, et du coup je me suis dit s'il n'y a pas un moyen de vous rendre un petit peu le truc,
sachant que j'ai déjà fait une vidéo sur le bac l'année dernière, qui est toujours valable.
C'est une vidéo sur les conseils généraux autour du bac de philo.
C'est dans la description.
Bref, je me suis dit que ce serait sympa de faire un petit truc, juste un petit truc,
parce que là il est vendredi soir, il est actuellement une heure du matin.
Et donc j'ai cherché un truc rapide à vous faire et j'ai pensé à un abécédaire.
Et en plus ça va me permettre de mettre un peu plus de clarté dans la chaîne,
c'est-à-dire, sur chaque concept ou chaque mot, vous dire :
"Là c'est intéressant d'aller voir cette vidéo pour ce concept là ou cette explication là, etc."
Voilà, c'est parti !
A comme "Absolu".
Quelque chose d'absolu, c'est quelque chose qui va être porté à son degré maximal.
C'est-à-dire sans aucune limite, par exemple "l'amour absolu" ou "la liberté absolue".
C'est quelque chose qui s'oppose donc à "relatif".
Ça peut aussi être quelque chose qui s'auto-suffit.
B comme "Bonheur".
Le bonheur, c'est vraiment un truc qu'on recherche tous.
Tous les Hommes recherchent le bonheur.
Et du coup, il y a pas mal de philosophes qui ont essayé d'y apporter des solutions
sur des moyens pour y arriver, etc.
Les deux gros, c'est le stoïcisme et l'épicurisme qu'on a vus ensemble.
J'ai fait un tableau comparatif que je vous mets dans la description,
et j'ai même fait une vidéo sur le stoïcisme et une vidéo sur l'épicurisme.
Pareil, tout est dans la description.
Tout sera, de toute façon, tout le temps dans la description, OK ?
Je ne vais pas faire d'annotation, sinon ça va être trop lourd.
C comme "Conscience".
La conscience, c'est la connaissance qu'a l'Homme de ses sentiments, de ses pensées, de ses actes.
En gros, la conscience, on peut la qualifier :
ça peut être la bonne conscience, la mauvaise conscience,
et souvent elle va de pair avec le préconscient et l'inconscient.
L'inconscient, c'est un truc dont j'ai parlé dans le Coup de Phil' n°5 sur Freud et Jamy.
D comme "Déterminisme".
Le déterminisme, c'est le principe qui dit que tous les phénomènes sont liés par des relations de causalité,
c'est-à-dire des relations de cause à effet.
Et donc, cela veut dire qu'il n'y a pas de hasard.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus sur le déterminisme, ça a été vachement développé par Spinoza,
et c'est dans la vidéo du Coup de Phil n°10.
E comme "Empirisme".
L'empirisme, c'est une philosophie qui dit que toutes nos connaissances viennent de l'expérience.
Quand je parle d'expérience, je parle pas d'expériences chimiques,
je parle de l'expérience, les choses que t'expérimentes au jour le jour.
S'il n'y avait pas d'expérience, on n'aurait pas eu de connaissance.
Ça a été vachement développé par John Locke, et il y a un coup de Phil' dessus.
C'est le coup de Phil' n°14.
F comme "En fait/En droit".
Dans une copie de philo,
tu ne peux pas dire "En fait" comme tu me dirais dans la vraie vie :
"Ouais, en fait, c'était pas mal..."
Non, "En fait", dans une copie de philo, c'est "Dans les faits",
c'est-à-dire quelque chose qui existe.
"En droit", c'est ce que t'es en droit de te demander,
genre, si c'est légitime, si c'est justifié, si c'est légal, ou des choses comme ça.
Ça existe en fait, mais est-ce que c'est fondé en droit ?
G comme "Genèse".
C'est le développement, la formation de quelque chose,
et c'est aussi le permier livre de la Bible.
H comme "Hédonisme".
L'hédonisme, c'est une doctrine qui fait du plaisir le principe ou le but de la vie.
Alors, attention parce que dans le sens courant,
ça veut une dire un petit peu la course au plaisir de manière immodérée,
et ce n'est pas ce que dit le sens littéral.
I comme "Intrinsèque".
Si A est intrinsèque à B, ça veut dire que A est inclus dans la nature ou la définition de B.
J comme "Justice'.
Alors, elle peut être commutative, comme dans le commerce, par exemple.
C'est quand ce qui est dû à chacun peut être interchangeable,
c'est-à-dire que tu dois rendre autant que tu reçois.
Ou elle peut être distributive, c'est que qu'on adjuge à chacun en fonction du mérite.
En gros, on distribue les peines et les récompenses.
K comme "Kant".
Alors, je vais pas m'étaler sur Kant ici dans cette vidéo, j'en dis déjà beaucoup dans le Coup de Phil' n°15.
L comme "Libre-arbitre".
Alors, c'est vachement important, c'est la capacité à être la première cause de vos actes.
C'est vachement lié aussi à l'existentialisme de Sartre,
donc je vous invite à aller voir le coup de Phil' n°4,
qui vous donnera une meilleure idée de ce que c'est le libre-arbitre.
M comme "Morale".
Alors, la morale c'est les objectifs qu'on se donne et les moyens d'y parvenir.
Donc du coup il y a différentes morales selon chaque philosophie :
par exemple, il y a la morale stoïcienne, il y a la morale épicurienne, y a la morale kantienne...
Mais je pense qu'on ne peut pas parler de morale,
ou, en tout cas, on peut parler de morale mais c'est vachement cool, d'aller voir la morale de Machiavel,
parce qu'il se met un peu à contre-pied par rapport à tout ça,
en tout cas, il a une vision vachement intéressante.
C'est le Coup de Phil' n°2.
N comme "Nécessaire".
"Nécessaire", c'est ce qui ne peut pas ne pas être.
C'est forcément là, et ça s'oppose à "contingent", ce qui peut ne pas être.
O comme "Objectif".
Quelque chose d'objectif, c'est quelque chose qui existe en dehors de ton esprit,
ou alors ça existe dans ton esprit, mais sans interprétation.
Et l'inverse, du coup, c'est "subjectif".
P comme "Paradigme".
"Paradigme", c'est une vision du monde en fait :
par exemple, avant on pensait que la Terre était plate,
on a appris que la Terre était ronde, OK, nouveau paradigme.
On pensait que tout tournait autour de la Terre, en fait on s'est rendu compte que la Terre tournait autour du Soleil,
très bien, nouveau paradigme.
C'est une vision du monde.
Q. Cul c'est la partie du corps préférée de tout philosophe qui se respecte.
R comme "Réalité" et "Raison".
Est-ce que ma raison peut m'aider à voir si le monde qui m'entoure est vraiment réel ?
En tout cas, c'est la question que se pose Descartes, et il essaye d'y répondre avec le "Cogito".
J'en parle dans le Coup de Phil' n°6.
S comme "Sensible".
Alors attention, quelque chose qui est sensible c'est pas quelque chose qui va pleurer pour rien,
c'est juste quelque chose qui va être perçu par les sens.
T comme "Transcendant".
Si A est transcendant à B, alors A dépasse, surpasse B. A est au delà de B.
U comme "Utilitarisme".
L'utilitarisme, c'est une doctrine morale pour laquelle une action bonne,
c'est une action qui a pour but le plus grand bonheur au plus grand nombre.
V comme "Volonté de puissance".
La volonté de puissance, c'est un concept vachement important chez Nietzsche.
Si vous voyez pas ce que c'est, je vous renvoie vers le Coup de Phil' n°17 sur le Surhomme.
W comme "Double volonté de puissance".
C'est comme la volonté de puissance, mais c'est deux fois plus puissant.
X comme "XGDHHDLIJILFDJPODKKFO".
DSDZFIJPGO Bjr JfiJUIGJKOG
XFFFFFFFFGGGGGG
AZERTYUIOPQSDFGHJKL
HFIOJSKPF"5--'àohdjkshqVHJK
JHFOIJPJDOJOPUFJK?DKLHNj'en ai marre de traduireT64T7YOUIJFLKJIOFO
BIFGHIJKKJKKàç_è-('"é"'(-è_çàç_è-'"é"'(-è_ç
À Á Â Ã Ä Å Æ Ç È É Ê Ë Ì Í Î Ï Ð Ñ Ò Ó Ô Õ Ö Ø Œ Š þ Ù Ú Û Ü Ý Ÿ
Le Y c'est le iota, c'est la neuvième lettre de l'alphabet grec.
C'est le I grec.
Z
C'est pas évident de finir cet alphabet, nan.
J'espère que ça vous a plu. Voilà c'est une petite vidéo qui va être là juste pour ce bac de 2015,
elle va sûrement être mise à jour en 2016, avec les nouvelles vidéos que j'aurais sorties pour mieux agencer tout ça
(ou alors elle sera supprimée avant, j'en sais rien).
Je balance ça un petit peu comme ça, j'espère que ça va vous aider,
et surtout ça ne se substitue à rien, ça ne suffit pas,
c'est juste des petits goodies mais ça ne remplace pas des vraies révisions.
Je me suis rendu compte que j'ai oublié de vous dire deux choses :
1. Bonne chance ;
2. Continuez à vous intéresser à la philo même après le bac.
Que ce soit via ma chaîne ou via autre chose, surtout continuez,
si ça vous a plu.
Voilà.
Et le matin quand vous allez à l'épreuve : "l’œil du Tigre".
L’œil du Tigre, mec.